[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you just tapped into the group chat live
in the bleacher report at presented by
fanduel i'm greg ivory alongside aaron
you're sixers playing again tonight at
what point do you stop calling him your
sixers
i think the fact that the simmons drama
is still going on which we will not get
into but just in general i'm gonna have
to keep calling them my sixers just
cause i'm from philadelphia but it's
it's getting hard to say
you gotta stay loyal and you gotta stay
loyal as always we're giving away locks
we're giving away hoodies and we're
giving away jerseys so get in the
comments
i need gifts i need emojis but most
importantly i need winners only please
matter of fact
i'm in the comments right now giving
away jersey goat garden says
step by five shout out to you go garden
uh g quinn 24 says steph will have
more he will have 36 and kd will have 32
shout out to you uh demon spies one says
no kyrie no worries dubs hashtag curry
everybody that i mentioned you are
walking away with a hoodie aaron today
is tuesday you know what that means it's
tnt tuesday fanduel is boosting the 3x2
in both games making it
three by two tuesday
the question is will there be two
three-pointers in the first three
minutes of the game last week the three
by two cash in the portland clippers
game let's take a look
yeah there it is
there it is they're going to swing the
ball around here i thought the tune was
going to put it up
[Music]
give it to me uh we asked you on twitter
which three by two will cash tonight
will it be golden state taking on the
nets or is it philadelphia taking on
utah jazz
aaron uh here's the result here's the
results
wow out of all the shows we've done this
has been the you know longest odds or
percentage i should say there 86 yeah
this is the most
it's definitely the one of the most
lopsided uh
polls that we've ran but i think that
there's a reason i think that there's a
reason and aaron which of these do you
like best
so i'm going with the public on this
warriors and the nets no two ways about
it steph curry leads the league with 63.
or excuse me 67
pointers made he's had four games with
at least seven three pointers so far
we're gonna see two of the top scorers
in the league go head to head kd
and curry and of course we're gonna talk
about that throughout the show but just
in general i have to rock with this game
the first game going with the public
there and i'm surprised those odds
aren't longer than minus 110 so
definitely jump on the fanduel
sportsbook and start betting this
hop on the train listen to aaron
everybody but i'm in the comments aaron
i'm in the comments uh they're shooters
in that game aaron that's why i'm
telling them to listen to you they're
shooters all around the floor in that
game this would be smart if i could make
that bed
yeah i got i got a
bugsy moe says
both three by two tonight so shout out
to you buzzy moe's you are walking away
with a hoodie eric reinhardt says eric
reinhardt says both
they're showing love to both rabbit
tools uh that means it's gonna be a real
good day
if both three by two's cash i got one
more hoodie in me aaron i got one more
hoodie i think we're gonna just decide
with this one uh i got
enderman enderman says lock in the
golden state warriors versus brooklyn
shout out to you enderman everybody
we are riding with the golden state
warriors versus the brooklyn nets as the
3x2 that we are all riding together uh
so
let's make this money we need sunsets in
the comments everybody needs sunsets in
the comments
goodbye aaron we asked
yes good vibes only please uh we asked
you in the app who will have more points
tonight will it be steph or will it be
kevin durant get in the comments and
tell us who will have more points at the
end of the game we'll dm one random
person who guessed correctly and hook
you up with a jersey aaron what do you
think is it steph or is it katie
everyone's talking about this question
so kd leads the nba scoring race to 30
points per game shooting a career best
59 meanwhile curry is second in the nba
scoring race with an average of 28
points per game on 44 shooting and get
this 39
from the three-point range but
look people are making the argument kd
does have a
a sore shooting shoulder sorry that's
very hard to say the 3s is there
according to reports so this is not
impacting his numbers the nets are
number two in the league and three-point
defense so i think they'll be able to
shut down steph curry you could also
make the argument that joe harris isn't
playing but nonetheless i'm rocking with
kd in you know his home court i think
he's gonna be able to get it done
obviously steph curry is an unbelievable
shooter but i just think in this game in
particular he's going to make a
statement so i'm rocking with kd
love that pick aaron love that pick uh
i've watched kevin durant closely being
a golden state warriors fan these last
couple of years i mean i know he's been
off the team for a couple years now but
before that we had him for three years
and
kevin durant shows up for those big time
games he shows up he usually shows up so
with that being said
this is a big game he's facing his
former team
kevin durant will show up so
i think he's going to score more points
than steph curry tonight there's nobody
on this warriors team there's nobody in
the nba that can stop kevin durant
one-on-one so i think he's gonna get his
tonight now do that mean are they gonna
win no that doesn't necessarily mean
that they're going to win but kd is
going to get his tonight so i'm going to
rock with kd uh but remember after the
game we're going to hit up one person
and hook you up with a jersey fan duel
is also offering a step in kd boost
so uh yes they are if they both scored
30 or more points uh it's being boosted
from plus 190 to plus 250 so if you
think they're both going off
get on the fanduel app and sprinkle on
that errand
do you like this boost or not
well katie has racked up seven 30-point
game so far this season meanwhile steph
curry has four 30 or more point games
already this season so
very
good lucky chance this will happen it's
great money at plus 250 so
i would bet this for sure
aaron let me hop in here let me hop in
get into this comments i see sunsets
shout out to everybody with the sunsets
young gravy says steph he will not go
off tonight and kevin will score 45
shout out to you young gravy for walking
away with a hoodie uh nicole marquez
says katie will score more points
tonight playing against his old squad at
home and he's been leading the league in
scoring best believe he will give it to
the warriors shout out to you nicole
marquez you are also walking away with
the hoodie aaron let's talk major
markets money lines against the spread
and points totals for tonight's game
let's take a look at the odds aaron what
are you seeing here and what do you like
so i'm gonna stick with this first game
since everyone's talking about the
warriors and then that's the best bet of
the night for me golden state to cover
this is just the second time the
warriors are underdogs it was at three
and a half earlier obviously i liked
that line better than a plus three but i
would still take it a plus three this is
going to be a competitive game of course
with you know a lot of talk surrounding
the warriors and guess they're off to a
great start and you know but they were
playing at home they're not playing
against amazing teams as opposed to the
nets being able to get those wins and
kind of they started off a little bit
shaky and they weren't winning some of
the games at home but i think this is
gonna be a game where the warriors are
gonna be able to keep it close just like
their other two losses they only lost by
a combined seven points in their two
losses so i'm gonna rock with the golden
state warriors to cover tonight
aaron that is a great bet because i am
following you i'm following you and i'ma
keep it simple i just i'm confused as to
why the better team
is the underdog here why is the better
team the underdog here is does vegas
have something up their sleeve i don't
know but i'm i'm walking into this one
with my heart with my team i'm rocking
with my team i'm rocking with the
warriors in the plus of three and i'm
sprinkling on the money line uh i do see
us one in this one so uh let's go
lawyers but it's not about what i think
it's not about everything it's about
what you guys think and i'm in the
comments right now giving away hoodies
cdub 75 says harden might show off
tonight
shout out to uc dub uh you are walking
away with a hoodie richie 21 says
curry's going for 37.
shout out to you i love you party
i love when people are so specific in
the comments like how did you come up
with that exact number
hey they get creative in the comments
they get creative in the comments uh g
quinn 24 he said that we're agreeing we
always agree
me and aaron we all we vibe we vibe
shout out to everybody we're really
we're all
ways we're on the same page
yeah we're on the same page but you are
all walking away with the hoodie we
talked to major mark it's aaron now
let's talk player props we're going to
play a little game called block or not
i'm going to put up a prop and you guys
get in the comments to tell me if it's a
lock or it's not
let's get right to it first up is
donovan mitchell to be the top scorer
in tonight's sixers jazz game the odds
are at -175
is that a lot or not aaron what is your
take
so he's averaging 26 points per game
right now for me while this may seem a
lock because there's great value this is
something that i would stay away from
just considering that they have not
really been playing well and then on the
other side of the ball you have tobias
harris and tyreese maxie really having
to step up since joel embiid has been
out the last four games due to covid but
tyrese maxi in the last four games
scored 26 tobias harris 23 points those
are their two averages um and i kind of
think in this game
just considering that one person is
going to have to stand on the other side
of the ball and maybe they would score
more than donovan mitchell but he needs
a game to be able to do this i just
wouldn't bet it at minus 175 that's just
way too much juice for me
aaron i agree
i agree that minus 175 is a lot of juice
but
hey i think that donovan mitchell will
be the top scorer in tonight's game he's
the best player on the court and usually
when donovan is having a good game the
utah jazz team is having a good game so
uh
i'm gonna hop into congress and see who
they like i'ma hop in the comments
lock for jazz my guys slick big 87 says
this is a lot for mitchell
but the jazz might lose still shout out
to you slick big 8487
you are walking away with hoodie the
next up is seth curry over
two and a half three pointers made this
is plus money aaron you like this one
yes so plus money you have to take this
he's already averaging this number right
now and three pointers made per game and
then just adding the fact that joel
embiid will not be on the floor kind of
gives the other players even more chance
to shoot the ball so definitely take the
over at plus money
yes i like it i like it i like it uh
seth curry has been balling lately he
he's got that clutch gene going for that
philadelphia 76ers team
he's just he's he's a splash brother go
go get go get two and a half threes
and it's plus money go get it uh let me
hop into the comments let me hop into
the comments uh
i got robert mark said that is a lock
that is a lock steph curry shout out to
you marvel
robert mark223 you are walking away with
a hoodie finally we have andre drummond
to grab over
13 and a half rebounds sitting at minus
102 aaron do you like this
so andre drummond is currently averaging
18 rebounds per game in the last four
games with joel embiid out i like this
line it is short there's limited juice
and right now considering he's at 13 and
a half i mean i feel like you have to
take the over at that even though it's
minus 102 i get it minus money barely
you got to take you over on that one too
gotta take the over i like it aaron i'm
following i love the stat that you just
dropped too
says he's recorded 18 18 rebounds per
game in the last four games this line
sitting at 13 and a half just do the
math people do the math aaron's
providing the statistics just do the
math i am riding with it i'm writing
with it uh let me see what the people
are riding with over here let me see if
the people is riding with us uh eighth
afraid
42 says no
says no um
they're grabbing them
c ronis c rona says drummond is the
rebound king with joel out it is a lock
shout out to uc ronis you're walking
away with a hoodie we love your good
vibes uh
aaron we know the people at home we know
they all love the fanduel same game
parlay so br betting is now building our
own and giving you guys the opportunity
to ride with us and tonight on inside
the nba pregame show chuck is gonna look
at our parlay and pick his favorite leg
before i tell you what it is i need you
to get in the comments and tell me what
do you
think of the parlay which legs or locks
and which legs are
not this week i'm looking at the
warriors taking on the nets of course
we're gonna cover this game
let's get right
to it let's get right to it starting it
off aaron you might call him the
babyface assassin you might call him
steph curry but you know what i like to
call him
30
30. go get four go make four threes
thirty just go make four or threes you
do that in your sleep
i like it uh give me that let's move on
we talked about kevin durant
i mentioned to you guys how i think that
nobody can guard him
not even draymond green who's
probably gonna win the defensive player
of the year probably but he still can't
guard slim so uh
kd
go get 30 points tonight go get 30 uh
it's a big time game and kd shows up in
those big time games moving on to james
harden i think that is going to be a
heavy dose of james harden and kevin
durant for the nets so with that being
said james harden go get 20 points
that's all we need we only need 20.
moving on aaron
actually actually aaron
i need a vibe check i need a vibe check
give me give me advice
i mean we know curry could potentially
go off we know kd he's already had seven
games where he's had over 30 plus points
and then we have hardin 20 plus points
that's what he's averaging right now and
he's had some games that he's gone off
and recently he had 39 points against
the pelicans last friday so again i mean
it's the pelicans but still he's
stepping up in those uh in some of the
games recently so hitting over for his
points is great too we're just obviously
expecting a lot of these stars to go off
so we'll see how that dynamic works
tonight
thank you aaron for the vibe check
i felt the vibes i felt those good vibes
and we're going to round this one off
with another superstar draymond green
draymond green go grab eight rebounds
aaron you sent me good vibes on the
first three picks how are you feeling
about this last one
i mean draymond green for his rebounds
they're always cash into the over so i
like this eight plus rebounds mean
that's what he's averaging right now so
it makes a lot of sense especially in a
big time game
here we go we got the good vibes for
aaron let's pull up this ticket so we
can show the people at home if you guys
put a hundred dollars down that is what
you're walking away with a cool five
hundred
cool fight three dollars you know
and some change and some change yeah i
like that too uh you guys can get on
fanduel and ride with this aaron before
i get into the comments
what are you grading the br betting
parlor
i'm gonna give this one an a minus just
can't give it a full a only because all
these stars obviously have to go off for
this parlay to hit but there's a great
chance that happens so i'm all for the
parlay giving it an a minus and i think
this is our first a
that i've given out basically in that
category of a thing you got a plus a and
then a minus
this is the first a that aaron gave out
like
those are really good vibes i need
sunsets in the comments i need sunsets
in the comments giving out hoodies just
for the good vibes uh
i'm in the comments i'm in the comments
i have to see if they are rocking with
our parlay mike steve ritter says needed
he's rocking with us shout out to you
mike steve ritter you're walking away
with hoodie uh here we go i got
dg2787 says seven boards for green
tonight that those are bad vibes but
unfortunately i mean fortunately we're
still giving you a hoodie dg uh i got
one more in me aaron one more in me
actually
i'm gonna give away a jersey i'm gonna
give away a jersey here and i'm feeling
generous
i am feeling generous to give away a
jersey and i'm in the comments
i'm in the comments and i see
i see g queen 24
g quinn 24 says our parlay looks like
easy money and then he mentioned winners
only please shout out to you g coin24
you are walking away
with a jersey aaron hop in there what's
your favorite comment
um pj heat 0-307 yo greg and aaron curry
easy over four threes made he averages
five kds averaging almost 30 games so he
will easily score over 30 against his
former team hardin will score over 20 in
his sleep dre will grab over eight
rebounds that was a long comment i
appreciate that so we have to give him
audi
yes yes yes love the vibes love the take
aaron the bulls are looking hot right
now they're looking hot
the big three demar derozan lonzo ball
and zach levine went off last night
let's take a look
here we got zach levine driving baseline
hey
don't jump when zach levine is jumping
and then oh my god lonzo looks like he's
back at ucla with that one and lonzo
from the corner
and and look at my guy look he look the
poetry in motion he looks like kobe he
grew up idolizing kobe that was demar
derozan with the shot i need you guys to
get in the comments and tell me if the
bulls
can win it all let's take a look at the
latest odds the bulls are currently
sitting that
plus
3 900 to win the finals airing that's
that good value
well obviously it's good value
considering it's plus 3 900 right now
it's a team that people are betting on
like the warriors and the brooklyn nets
to win it all it's kind of one of those
long shots that people are liking i mean
you're looking at the bulls right now
without nikola busevich and they're
still staying afloat demar derozan has
been spectacular as we just saw in that
clip they're 10-4 with big wins over the
nets lakers clippers mavs and their only
loss in the last five games five games
was to the warriors so i mean absolutely
impressive and i think a lot of people
are going to want to continue to bet
this team and granted that you get it at
3900 right now i would grab it before
that lessons if they keep winning
yes aaron is
saying take it she says put some money
on it uh i'm in the comments i want to
see what they're talking about aaron i
want to see what the comments are
talking about uh jt for mvp says no he
says no
mark one says i think the bulls need
more veteran leadership shout out to you
mark when you're walking away with a
hoodie uh
uh
d-boy 22 say this ain't it he's ain't
rocking with the bulls uh i don't blame
you i mean d-boy the bulls is a good
team they are a good team but i like
them going to state warriors i think
that they have strength in numbers
2.0 we won would strengthen numbers back
in 2015. at least strengthen numbers 2.0
we got the young guys
got the veterans back clay's coming back
for the rest
it might get nasty for the rest of the
league aaron uh
i think i think it might be time to take
this home home man
yeah thank you guys thank everybody for
tapping into the group chat presented by
fanduel remember what you learned today
the warriors nets 3x2 is a lock steph is
going off get on the fanduel app entail
the br betting same game parlay and tune
in to inside the nba's pregame show to
see chuck
pick his favorite leg of our parlay
we'll be back next week giving out more
hoodies more jerseys and most
importantly more locks if you want a
hoodie today we will dm you and you know
what i'm going to give out one more
hoodie right now just for the fun of it
i'm in the comments man i'm in the
comments bad pork steak says
i think the heat are looking pretty good
this year the one at all bad sports says
the heat is looking pretty good shout
out to you bad sports takes and shout
out to them um
yeah yeah yeah
it's bassworth thanks you're walking
away with a hoodie make sure you guys
get on fair do ride with us follow us on
social alongside aaron dolan i'm greg
ivory we are leaving the group chat
peace
[Music]
[Music]
you